TOWARD IT THOUGH ASKING IN A
HEARING WHAT'S THE HARM IN
APPOINTING THAT SPECIAL MASTER.
>>> A DAY AFTER HE OFFERED SHARP
CRITICISMS OF THE MAGA MOVEMENT
IN A PRIMETIME ADDRESS IN
PHILADELPHIA, PRESIDENT BIDEN
OFFERED THIS FURTHER
EXPLANATION.
>> I DON'T CONSIDER ANY TRUMP
SUPPORTER TO BE A THREAT TO THE
CONSIDER.
I DO THINK ANYONE WHO CALLS FOR
THE USE OF VIOLENCE, FAILS TO
CONDEMN VIOLENCE WHEN USED,
REFUSES TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN AN
ELECTION HAS BEEN WON, INSISTS
UPON CHANGING THE WAY IN WHICH
THE RULES YOU COUNT VOTES.
THAT'S A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> AND JOINING ME NOW TO TALK
ABOUT THIS, IS FORMER REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN JOE WALSH AND
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST MARIA
CARDONA.
WE HEARD REPUBLICANS LIKE THE
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY DEMAND THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN APOLOGIZE FOR INVOKING THE
IDEA OF FASCISM TO DESCRIBE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS.
>> JOE BIDEN DOESN'T OWE AN
APOLOGY TO ANYBODY.
19 TO 20 MONTHS AGO, DONALD
TRUMP LED AN EFFORT TO VIOLENTLY
OVERTHROW AN AMERICAN ELECTION.
HERE WE ARE IN SEPTEMBER OF
2022.
80% OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY DOES
NOT ACCEPT JOE BIDEN AS THEIR
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE.
AND I'M GLAD, JIM, THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN ADDRESSED THAT
AND CALLED OUT VIOLENCE AND
CALLED OUT A PHILOSOPHY.
LOOK, I COME FROM MAGA WORLD, HE
DIDN'T CALL OUT TRUMP VOTERS.
HE CALLED OUT THE MEGA
PHILOSOPHY, WHICH IS
ANTI-DEMOCRACY.
>> MARIA, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS?
WHAT CAN THE PRESIDENT DO TO
BRING IN MORE REPUBLICANS FROM
THE MODERATE WING OF THE PARTY
INTO THE FOLD?
DO YOU THINK HE ACCOMPLISHED
THAT THE OTHER NIGHT AND COULD
HE DO MORE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT IN
THE FUTURE?
>> I THINK HE STARTED TO, JIM.
AND I THINK WHAT HE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO DO, AND I THINK HE
WILL, IS NOT ONLY CALLING OUT
THIS HUGE THREAT THAT IS THE
MAGA EXTREMIST AGENDA AND THOSE
WHO FOLLOW IT, INCLUDING MORE
THAN 80 REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
WINNERS, WHO COULD BE IN A
POSITION TO HAVE CONTROL OVER
ELECTIONS IF THEY WIN IN
NOVEMBER, SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CALL THAT OUT AND TELL AMERICANS
IT IS IN OUR HANDS TO PROTECT
OUR DEMOCRACY.
BUT WHAT I HOPE THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN CONTINUES TO ALSO DO IS TO
UNDERSCORE HOW IMPORTANT A
TRADITIONAL, COMMON SENSE,
SMART, DEMOCRACY RESPECTING
REPUBLICAN PARTY WE NEED IN
ORDER TO HAVE A VIABLE TWO-PARTY
HEALTHY AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
SO I THINK IF HE CONTINUES TO DO
THAT, TO UNDERSCORE THAT HE IS
CALLING ON COMMON SENSE,
TRADITIONAL REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
THE ONES WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY DONALD TRUMP
AND THE MAGA AGENDA IS AND ALL
OF THE SO-CALLED LEADERS THAT
ARE FOLLOWING HIM AND REFLECTING
AT HIS ALTER CONTINUE TO CALL
THEM OUT AND SAY, LOOK, WE NEED
A HEALTHY REPUBLICAN PARTY SO WE
CAN CONTINUE TO FIGHT ON THE
BATTLEFIELD OF IDEAS FOR WHAT IS
BEST FOR THIS COUNTRY.
BUT UNTIL THAT HAPPENS, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE IN A POSITION WHERE
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO CALL OUT
THESE DEVASTATING AND DANGEROUS
LIES THAT ARE PART AND PARCEL OF
THE MAGA ULTRA EXTREMIST AGENDA.
>> JOE, LET'S REMIND OUR VIEWERS
OF THIS MOMENT THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAD AS PRESIDENT IN 2020 WHEN HE
REFERRED TO PEOPLE ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE AS FASCIST.
LET'S WATCH.
>> GOING LEFT WING ON THE WAY.
FASCISTS.
THEY ARE FASCISTS.
SOME OF THEM.
NOT ALL OF THEM, BUT SOME OF
THEM.
BUT THEY'RE GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER.
WE HAVE TO WIN THIS ELECTION.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE'S SOME
PEARL CLUTCHING GOING ON OVER
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID GIVEN
WHERE WE'VE BEEN LATELY, GIVEN
THE RHETORIC THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAS USED?
>> JIM, I HAVE ZERO PATIENCE FOR
ANY TRUMP SUPPORTER WHO CALLS
JOE BIDEN DIVISIVE AFTER THE
DONALD TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
HERE'S BIDEN'S PROBLEM AND
AMERICA'S PROBLEM.
THE MAGA PHILOSOPHY, MOVEMENT,
IT'S NO LONGER SOME FRINGE
MOVEMENT WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
IT IS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND AMERICA REALLY NEEDS TO WRAP
ITS ARMS AROUND THAT AND I THINK
PRESIDENT BIDEN BEGAN TO PLAY A
REAL LEADERSHIP ROLE THE OTHER
NIGHT IN GETTING AMERICANS TO
UNDERSTAND THIS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A FRINGE
MOVEMENT.
AGAIN, 80% OF REPUBLICANS DO NOT
ACCEPT BASIC ELECTION RESULTS.
HELLO, THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
>> AND MARIA, TRUMP WILL BE IN
PENNSYLVANIA TONIGHT, STUMPING
FOR REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES, DOUG
MASTRIANO, RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR,
HE'S BEEN AN ELECTION DENIER,
HE'S ALSO OUT THERE TRYING TO
SUPPORT MEHMET OZ FOR THE
SENATE, WHO'S BEEN STRUGGLING IF
IF YOU BELIEVE THE LATEST POLLS
IN THIS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT AND DO
DEMOCRATS NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
THEY DON'T GET TOO COMPLACENT
WHEN IT GETS TO THIS CRIMINAL
BATTLEGROUND STATE?
>> 150,000% ON THAT LAST POINT,
JIM.
THE LAST THING DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
DO IS BE COMPLACENT.
THAT IS DANGEROUS.
WE HAVE TO STILL BE VERY
CONCERNED.
THE MOMENTUM IS CERTAINLY IN OUR
CORNER RIGHT NOW.
BUT WE HAVE TO PLAY LIKE WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY BEHIND IN BOTH THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
WE HAVE TO PLAY LIKE OUR
DEMOCRACY IS ON THE LINE BECAUSE
IT IS.
I ASSURE YOU THAT TONIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HEAR
MASSIVELY DESTRUCTIVE, DANGEROUS
LIES FROM DONALD TRUMP.
AND HERE'S WHAT I BELIEVE PEOPLE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT
AND REALIZE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE REJECTED THE
MAGA AGENDA IN 2018, JIM.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
REJECT THE MAGA AGENDA IN 2020.
THAT IS WHY JOE BIDEN WON
LEGITIMATELY BY A LONG SHOT.
IT WAS A HUGE WIN BY JOE BIDEN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, I BELIEVE,
WILL CONTINUE TO REJECT THE MAGA
EXTREMIST AGENDA BUT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO CALL IT OUT.
WE CANNOT BE COMPLACENT, THAT IS
THE LAST THING WE HAVE TO DO,
WHICH IS WHY I'M SO GLAD THAT
JOE BIDEN MADE THIS SPEECH A
COUPLE OF NIGHTS AGO TO PUT
EVERYONE ON NOTICE BECAUSE IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS AMERICAN IDEA, THIS
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, WHICH IS
STILL VERY FRAGILE, IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S GUARANTEE.
IT IS UPON ALL OF US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROTECT IT.
WE HAVE TO GO OUT AND, LIKE
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID, VOTE,
VOTE, VOTE.
>> THIS DEMOCR